is Marvel Studios developing a second
Logan film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel Studios does have plans
for Hugh Jackman's Wolverine after
Deadpool 3 in the
MCU hi hi that's right Wolverine is not
done after Deadpool 3 he is not just
coming back for one last film with
Deadpool with his buddy Ryan Reynolds
and then he's done again no he'll be
sticking around in the MC for several
more years appearing in at least one
other major project as the lead and some
insiders even hint that he could be
appearing in other projects as well but
with Hugh Jackman's involvement in the
MCU moving forward after Deadpool 3 does
that mean we are going to be getting
another Logan film recently Rumblings
and rumors have been going around online
stating that they could be developing A
Logan 2o since the director of Logan
previously in the past had stated that
he does want to do a second film film in
fact he publicly stated in October 2017
that he was just working on a script for
a spin-off of Logan featuring x23
mentioning ideas for either a second
Logan film or a spin-off of the first
film and recently I've been getting a
lot of questions about whether this is
true or not the recent rumors that A
Logan 2 could be happening well like I
said Logan does have a future in the MCU
it just might not be Logan 2 and I'll
break down everything that you need to
know about the future of Wolverine in
this video so don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest MCU
and Wolverine news now right away it
does make sense that Hugh Jackman
wouldn't just return as Wolverine for
one film to be one and done yes Ryan
Reynolds is one of his best friends yes
Ryan Reynolds is super convincing and
yes the world wants to see Wolverine and
Deadpool together on screen in a
Deadpool film that really is on its own
enough to come back but when you're
coming back to the the MCU and
everything is possible and connected and
Marvel Studios wants you to stay in the
MCU well for a lot of people that is a
dream come true in fact the original
X-Men cast many of them expressed that
they were kind of disappointed that they
debuted in the X-Men films at a time
where the MCU didn't exist and that they
would have loved to have been a part of
the MCU and now their dreams are coming
true with Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret
Wars now unfortunately James mangle did
say in 2019 that he is no longer working
on a Logan 2 or a spin-off to Logan I
really would not expect any type of
sequel to Logan in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as a whole entire film or
dedicated project we may however get a
glimpse into what could have been in
Deadpool 3 plus on top of that like I
mentioned Marvel Studios does have plans
for Hugh Jackman's Wolverine moving
forward after Deadpool 3 but first let's
start with what Deadpool 3 is about the
Multiverse is going to be falling apart
in fact we've recently heard a plot
synopsis for Deadpool 3 that a couple of
insiders my time to shine hello and can
we get some toast have said is real the
plot synopsis tells us about Deadpool
retiring hanging up the katas and
becoming a used car salesman until he
has to come back to being Deadpool to
save his family and friends so basically
what this is is the fox Universe
collapsing most likely due to an
incursion because the entire Multiverse
at this point in time in the MCU during
the events of Deadpool 3 is going to
start collapsing and of course this is
due to King the con and the instability
that him and all of his variants are
creating for the Multiverse so in order
to save everybody that he loves he has
to travel throughout the Multiverse and
what does he do along the way picks up
his old buddy Wolverine and of course
you know that Deadpool can break the
fourth wall and the same is going to be
true for Deadpool 3 he going to continue
to do that in fact what we've heard is
that Deadpool will visit many different
universes to try and find who the best
Wolverine is so we're going to see a lot
of different Wolverine variants here
that aren't Hugh Jackman the reason
they're not going to be Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine is because he will ultimately
According to some insiders decide that
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is the ultimate
Wolverine and breaking the fourth wall
in a jokingly matter he will say you
can't recast Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
now Hugh Jackman has confirmed that they
are not going to undo the events of
Logan meaning that variant of Wolverine
does indeed go on to die however we
essentially know how the MCU works now
Deadpool can show up at a time in fact
he can show up at that specific timeline
help Wolverine and x23 keep him from
dying and take him away and what will
actually happen is the universe in which
he took him away will then become a
branch timeline a timeline in which
Wolverine lived the other timeline would
go on to be the same where Wolverine
Logan would die so in this case our
Logan 2 really would kind of happen
inside of Deadpool 3 this is kind of
Marvel studios's plans anyways they're
going to take Wolverine from a timeline
at some different point throughout his
entire history since he's been on screen
and that's the variant they're going to
work with so it's going to be a
different variant than the person that
we saw as Logan in the movie that's how
they're not undoing what has happened
the Multiverse really does allow you to
have a lot of freedom so in Deadpool 3
we're going to see Wolverine and
Deadpool go out on a bunch of different
Adventures they'll visit many different
universes run into Old X-Men and this is
probably better than any Logan 2 that we
could probably get because Logan one was
amazing and usually when they do sequels
they're not as good as the first and
luckily for us like I've been mentioning
Marvel does have plans to keep Hugh
Jackman around for starters we have
heard that he is actually going to be
the lead if not one of the leads one of
the main characters of Avengers Secret
Wars we know that Avengers Secret Wars
the team is going to consist of many
different heroes from many different
universes so it's not just going to be
an Avengers team there will be Avengers
members from our universe and other
universes X-Men and the Fantastic Four
members heck Daredevil has returned we
know the Punisher is returning there's
rumors of Jessica Jones returning maybe
even some Defenders show up as well but
during this mass of people mass of
Heroes throughout all of these different
universes they're going to have to have
a leader or a few different leaders and
one of those leaders is supposed to be
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine so right away
his future in the MCU does not end with
Deadpool 3 but he's going on to have a
huge role in the finale of the
Multiverse Saga and if Marvel starts
stepping up their game Avengers Secret
Wars could be the biggest movie of all
time if executed properly but insiders
have also hinted that it's not just
Secret Wars that he's going to be a part
of and this does make sense because
Secret Wars really is going to be the
finale to everything that is happening
in the Multiverse Saga we know that the
Scarlet Witch has to return we know that
the Fantastic 4 have to enter the MCU we
know Doctor Strange 3 has to happen all
of these are going to be Multiverse
films they may not all focus on the
Multiverse like Doctor Strange 3 but
they will have Multiverse components for
example a rumor going around right now
is that the Fantastic Four or they're
going to debut in Another Universe then
by the end of their movie will'll make
their way into either the tva's kind of
official HQ for a bunch of Heroes that
they've been Gathering or they'll make
their way to the 616 Universe you see
another big thing happening in Deadpool
3 reportedly is that the TVA is going to
start to gather Heroes and I'm assuming
villains as well from a lot of different
collapsing and dying universes and put
them all into one spot it would make
sense that they put them in the TVA
since the TVA exists outside of time and
space and it would be really hard for
King the Conqueror and any of his
variants to find him there so perhaps
the Fantastic Four at the end of the
film get saved by the TVA because their
universe is being destroyed so then they
arrive at the TVA and perhaps Wolverine
meets them there and greets them and
says hello you are now part of something
way bigger than you thought if he is
going to be the leader of this new big
multiversal team it would make sense and
this could really happen in a lot of
other projects as well Doctor Strange 3
at the end he might run into this team
as well the Scarlet Witch could also
stum stumble upon them plus not to
mention our main heroes are going to
have to join this bigger team as well
our heroes from the 616 Universe we have
to have them meet Hugh Jackman and
Deadpool that's going to be a really big
thing so Hugh Jackman's Logan Wolverine
could show up at the end of Avengers 5
or in a post credit scene for Avengers 5
plus not to mention there are some
projects that are going to come in phase
six that we really don't know about yet
Marvel Studios has not officially
released the entire slate for phase six
and there have been reports from
insiders that state now that they've had
some trouble with Jonathan Majors that
they've had to let him go and Kang might
be sidelined for a little bit they might
bring in the X-Men sooner rather than
later we might actually get an X-Men
film if we get an X-Men film in the MCU
in one way or another we would assume we
would have Hugh Jackman's Wolverine in
that movie whether that's during the
entire movie perhaps it's a multiversal
X-Men film or towards the end if it's
X-Men characters from the 616 Universe
at the end they meet up with the
multiversal Avengers team in which again
Hugh Jackman would be one of the leaders
of and just to add it's also said that
Toby McGuire Spider-Man is going to be
one of the leaders as well which makes
sense it's been said that Kevin fagy is
looking at secret Warriors in Depo 3 as
a way to kind of say goodbye to the
characters that he's known loved and
worked with over time he began his
career with the very first X-Men film
working with Hugh Jackman it makes sense
that not only would Hugh Jackman want to
stick around longer to work with Kevin
feige who he worked with since the first
EXP film and vice versa Kevin fogy
wanting Hugh Jackman to stick around but
we're kind of getting a full circle
moment here it started with Wolverine
and the X-Men and now the Multiverse
Saga will end with Wolverine and the
X-Men and of course the Avengers and
Fantastic 4 Etc so although Logan 2 is
not going to happen we are essentially
getting more Wolverine movies and in a
lot of ways this is even better than
anything we could have hoped for we're
seeing Wolverine interact with Deadpool
and not in that X-Men Origins way not
only that but we're going to see him
interact with the Fantastic 4 and the
Avengers and he's going to be a main
character not a side character so the
future of Wolverine right now is pretty
epic and we don't even know all of the
details yet so be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news if we
hear anything else of course we'll do an
update video please let us know what you
think about this news please don't
forget to like the video and of course
if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 Xbox
series X some Marvel Legends items or
some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof